-Before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They don't always fit
in the commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
we mention all of them.
So it's time for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
-Our first sponsor
is Spectrum --
we hear your complaints,
and we don't care.
[ Applause ]
Head & Shoulders --
let everyone who uses your
bathroom know you have dandruff.
[ Laughter and applause ]
CNBC --
cornering the market in business
news and "Shark Tank" returns.
[ Applause ]
Guinness --
because sometimes
you're in the mood for
a tall, cold glass
of carbonated motor oil.
[ Laughter ]
Also sponsored by U-Haul --
think you can handle
driving a semi truck?
No? Perfect.
[ Applause ]
[ Squeaking ]
Cadbury --
we do creme eggs
for Halloween now.
Just go with it.
[ Laughter ]
Cinemax --
whoa, don't freak out,
we came free with HBO.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Athleta --
if you squint, you could
pretend we're Lululemon.
[ Applause ]
AT&T --
sorry, -ou're cutting ou-,
-ould you -epeat tha-?
[ Applause ]
Oat milk --
honestly, we started this
as a joke,
and then the thing just
kinda blew up.
[ Applause ]
Adidas --
the official track suit
for professional athletes
and background actors
in "The Sopranos" movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, Coors Light --
okay, fine, we confess,
it's just as cold
as every other beer.
[ Applause ]
And finally, "USA Today,"
because it's morning,
and you're in a hotel.
Well, that's all for
"Tonight Show Sponsors."